[Music]
hello I'm Ben Wattenberg a
constitutional amendment to balance the
budget is a key item in the republican
contract with America the House of
Representatives recently passed it now
the debate moves to the Senate but do we
really need to change the US
Constitution to get our books in order
how important is a balanced budget and
is there a political agenda behind the
debate joining us to sort through the
conflict and the consensus are four
leading economists from San Francisco
via satellite Milton Friedman Nobel
laureate in economics and senior
research fellow at the Hoover
Institution Herbert Stein
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers under presidents Nixon and Ford
and a senior fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute James Miller budget
director for President Reagan and John M
Olin Distinguished Fellow at the Center
for the Study of public choice at George
Mason University and Henry Aaron
director of economic studies at the
Brookings Institution and a former
chairman of the Advisory Council on
Social Security the topic before this
house the budget balancing act
this week on think-tank
[Music]
one of the most common stories in the
economic profession concerns
President Truman who after hearing so
many economists tell him on the one hand
this and on the other hand that turned
to his staff and growl find me a
one-armed economist and they're probably
still out looking in the 1980s the
federal deficit went way up and stayed
up according to the budget just
introduced by the Clinton administration
in 1995 the government will spend a
hundred and ninety three billion dollars
more than it will take in and the
deficit will continue at about that
level into the future moreover critics
say Congress won't stop this trend
because Congress is out of control
House Republicans say the best way to
rein in spending is to pass a
constitutional amendment that will force
Congress to balance the budget by the
year 2002 what they're saying is stop me
before I kill again but is the deficit
really so bad for the nation as a whole
the deficit as a share of our gross
domestic product is heading down so on
the one hand things don't look so bad in
fact some Democrats say that the crusade
for a balanced budget amendment
is really just a smokescreen for a
conservative ideology that wants to
strangle government by cutting off its
oxygen that is its ability to spend but
on the other hand look at this the
bipartisan Commission on entitlement and
tax reform projects that unless changes
are made the deficit will soar the 19
percent of our gross domestic product by
the year 2030 and that would be a
handful Milton Friedman in San Francisco
via satellite do we need a balanced
budget amendment we need a strong
balanced budget amendment such as was
proposed in the contract for America
with a tough tax limitation provision we
do not need the kind of weak balanced
budget amendment that was actually
passed by the Congress
okay harp Stein well I think you're
gonna find that that you need some
two-handed economists here because I
don't think we need a balanced budget
amendment either I don't think we need a
balanced budget amendment of either kind
I think our record except for a brief
spree during the Reagan period was not
so bad I think we are learning to do
better and I think that we will do
better without the amendment than with
it Henry Aaron I think we need to
balance the budget I think we can
balance the budget in fact by the year
2002 but I think a balanced budget
amendment will do absolutely nothing to
help us along the way
and will in short order be the source of
incentives for gimmickry it will bring
the courts into budget policy in a way
that I think everybody should deplore
and in short I think the balanced budget
amendment will stand in our way rather
than help us on the road to sound budget
policy Jim Miller I disagree with all
three of my colleagues here I say pride
I think we need a balanced budget
amendment though I would support the one
that that Milton was talking about I
don't think we ought to cast this one
away I think it would have some good
effects some research that I've done
with mark crane suggests that on the
other hand I think it would have an
effect it's not it would just be
gimmickry I think the result would be
that it would put discipline all members
of Congress the sort of discipline that
they'd sorely need but go ahead well
it's kind of assumes that this
discipline will be in the direction of
getting us a better budget policy now
there's no reason to think that the best
of all budget policies is to balance the
budget every year or every decade or
every generation we're not going to have
the best of all budget policies anyway
with or without the amendment the
question is whether without the
amendment we will have a chance of
coming closer and I think we will
because the the economy fluctuates the
cyclically
demography changes other requirements
change and the balanced budget amendment
is going to prevent us from making
rational adaptations to these changes in
the economy I don't believe that's
correct
the balon of the amendment as it was
originally proposed did not rule out
temporary deficits or surpluses it did
not require a balanced budget every year
the issue however is not being it seems
to me present it correctly the key issue
is not balancing the budget the key
issue is how do you keep spending from
growing at an intolerable rate as of
today governments federal state and
local spend about 43 percent of the
national income we're not getting our
money's worth and the trouble with a
weak balanced budget amendment which is
why I am against it is that it will tend
to drive Congress and will be dissing it
will have discipline as Jim says but
will tend to exert that discipline in
the way of higher taxes rather than
lower spending if that's what you
believe Milton then I think you should
make your case to the American public
and try and win it in a straight-up
fight in a democratic system not shackle
the budgetary process with rules that
are really not made for the next year or
the next five years and run for decades
let me ask you this we have rarely had
an election certainly in a congressional
year where the issues were at least
allegedly nationalized now Gingrich went
around with that contract for America
and he said this is what we're voting on
oh and well limit heat that's what he
said I know there's a lot of fuzz in
there but he percent of the public had
never heard of the contract and most of
those who had heard of it didn't know
what it said but this is all it's not a
that wasn't even an example of a
nationalization but let me say the
reason I think good conservatives should
be really upset at the prospect of a
balanced budget amendment as many
conservatives are such as Robert Bork
the editorial board of The Wall Street
Journal is that if we enact such an
amendment it is going to threaten I
think one of the great strengths of the
American economy that conservatives
would correctly pride compared to
European nations we have less government
spending we are less bureaucratic we
have fewer regulations it may be the
case that we are in the midst of a
conservative era currently
in a few years there may be a more
activist mood in Congress what would be
the easiest thing in the world to do
well mandate the private business do the
things that government now spends pay
unemployment insurance benefits pay
retirement benefits provide sickness
benefits one could in other words
replace because of the restrictions of a
balanced budget amendment the tendency
when there is a consensus about public
need for government to spend money and
raise regulations and mandates and about
what good conservatives should believe
you certainly have credentials as a good
conservative right but we're doing that
already that is to say that offloading
two mandates on state and local
governments and on the and on the
private sector I mean Milton's point
about 43% if you had regulation in there
Melton you get more like like fifty
thirty four percent according to the
OECD that Milton come in from
san-francisco nope no I think this is
much of this is beside the point
in the first place so far as the public
at large voting on it I'm making my case
in the public the balanced budget
amendment will only become part of the
Constitution if it's accepted by
three-quarters of the states that's
surely a chance for the public to
express their opinion on it we're not
trying to slip anything over in the
second place I want to emphasize that
I'm not a conservative I'm a liberal in
the good old-fashioned sense of a 19th
century liberal more likely a
libertarian and as such what I want to
do and what I believe the public at
large wants to do is to in in reagan's
phrase get the government off the back
of the people and the only way you can
do that is by having some kind of a
limit on government spending that's the
perfect good I saw requiring a 60%
majority for a tax
I think Milton is exactly right
one important and if not the most
important effect the balanced budget
amendment wouldn't be to circumscribe
the growth of government mark Crain and
I did some analysis of state regulatory
institutions some states have balanced
budget requirements in the Constitution
some have
as a matter of law some do not have him
there all sorts of different variations
we used as the as the dependent variable
growth of per capita spending in the
state what we found Milton and and herb
and Henry is that a balanced budget
requirement restrains the growth of
spending in the states and this happens
without regard to whether there is a
supermajority requirement for tax
increase but the public and the
political process they're going to have
to make a lot of very difficult
decisions about the budget the decisions
about the budget that are as important
as the total size of the budget or the
size of the deficit they have to decide
what is appropriate defense policy what
is appropriate welfare policy what is
appropriate health policy and these
questions cannot be resolved by a
constitutional amendment and they are no
different from the question about the
total size I want to just shift gears
for a moment for to help our audience
out let me put this question in the pot
our deficits really bad running deficits
year after year after year well I I
don't think you can answer that question
because it depends on what you're doing
with the money that you that you raised
through the deficit of course it's kind
of other things equal I think little
deficits are a little bad and big
deficits are big bad but I wouldn't
there are certainly circumstances for
which it is per entirely appropriate to
run a deficit herb is right I mean it's
in in in a perfect world you would run
surpluses sometimes you would run
deficits sometimes heard invented the
full employment surplus or balanced
budget formal employment with the
automatic stabilizers and all of that is
works the question though is we're not
in a perfect world would it make sense
to prevent the politicians in Washington
for using deficit for that elected your
kind of people we elected a jim miller
milton friedman kind of congress and you
don't trust I don't trust them look at
what now you hold it hold it you ran for
Senate in the primary in Virginia
against Oliver North you almost beat
them
right would you trust you if you were
there of course I would trust me we
don't trust you you're Republican
conservative I trust them too I don't
address this but I think I think we
ought to have a surplus now but when I
asked myself should we have a surplus
now I say yes it would be desirable and
it would be desirable because I can
think of three or four hundred billion
dollars worth of spending that's in the
budget that I would be willing to get
rid of by quarter to have the surplus
well I wouldn't get rid of I would get
rid of Medicare I would cut Medicaid
down very sharply I would start phasing
out Social Security I would get rid of
farm price supports I would get rid of
the small business and I get elected
well oh look that's not back if you go
ever touch one of those individually you
will not get elected right if you go
after them as a bundle that's a
different thing the I believe the views
of the American public tend to be
misunderstood if you ask the public do
you want to cut Social Security they'll
say no but if you ask them would you
rather eliminate the deficit by cutting
spending or by increasing taxes they
overwhelmingly say they want to cut well
anything we've asked them now since 1936
we've been asking them in public opinion
polls do you want to balance the budget
they always say overwhelmingly no and
they always overwhelmingly elect people
who never did balance the budget and he
gave no sign of ever wanting to balance
the budget I don't think the American
people really care very much could i
interject we had we may not have
balanced the budget to the nickel from
1945 until 1974 the ratio of the u.s.
debt to our productive capacity declined
by more than half that was the year I
left the government that was a year it
was it was then no it was because we
were running deficits that were much
smaller than the growth of the economy
if the deficits had been large it would
have grown in well whatever was it then
leveled off until 1981 these are facts
milton i know i
1981 we entered an era where we cut
taxes raise spending and really lied to
the American public about the probable
fiscal consequence the debt declined as
a fraction of income not because we ran
small surpluses small deficits but
because we inflated the debt away we
repudiated a large fraction of the debt
we were paying interest rates on the
debt which was below the rate of
inflation that's how the debt was
reduced all right let me talk about
something that maybe I know something
about which is public opinion which you
all learned it economists to have
discussed and and and politics
I've been around Washington long enough
to say you know what is the hidden
agenda and it's not even very hidden in
this discussion Milton Friedman says he
doesn't care for the budget is balanced
he doesn't like government he says the
government is picking your pocket so why
are you arguing I mean isn't this being
somewhat deceitful it is to say all
we're talking it's good for the economy
it's good for this it's good for that in
fact why don't you get out there and say
government is bad for us and this is
what we're talking about now to balance
the budget amendment this is a political
agenda well look I mean you have too
much government I think that's what the
election was about balancing the budget
is a very appealing to people it will
have the effect as Milton said of
restraining the avarice of the federal
government and I think that's good I
thought herb was saying that you can use
the balanced budget amendment or Henry
to go up I don't think that's correct
but but I think the answer is to your
question is that we have a
responsibility to tell the American
people what their choices are and if we
think that the government if I believe
to say the government is too big by
itself is really meaningless without
specifying what the government is doing
I think we should confront the American
people with this choice do you are
Medicare do you want Social Security do
you want to select all right Milton he
said I just want a matter the level of
government what do you say I'm saying
herb that what you're saying is not fair
those of us who have been who think
government has been doing too much have
specified over and over again what we
think needs to be done have over and
over again
arrghh
for example privatization of Social
Security so that it's not fair to
criticize them on the ground yeah but
I'm just criticizing all these people in
the Congress who have never said
anything like that well that may well be
I think it's also important you
mentioned public opinion been the I
mention it because you all mention yes
well okay the American public has
consistently said they want lower taxes
and a balanced budget they have also
said when asked about specific
activities of government that they want
to maintain or even expand everything
that they're asked specifically about
with two exceptional public in it
welfare in foreign aid so public opinion
in this field is mush it's inconsistent
in its margin it's wrong it's
inconsistent welcome questions at our
end because the questions that are asked
they say two things no excuse me for a
moment if you ask a person do you want
to eliminate one thing which he benefits
from the rational answer is no but if
you give them a package if you give them
a bundle and say do you want the only
way we can cut government is by cutting
a lot of things we had that example in
connection with the closing of the
military bases you couldn't get anyone
closed when you try to get it alone when
you had a package of it on a dick
Armey's proposal
you got faces closed let me ask you this
Henry I mean I just asked the the
Conservatives Jim Miller and Milton
Friedman whether I'm a conservative I'm
sorry the conservative and libertarian
faction of this panel whether they
weren't really promoting a not so hidden
agenda they weren't just talking about
the the budget amendment but they were
talking about they would like to defund
the welfare state and this is one way to
do it and my sense is that the politics
on the other side you are all talking
about well it would be hard to adjust it
in hard to written some time we ought to
have deficits but you guys want to keep
the welfare state you have to have high
spending to do it is that the political
agenda over there well it's not it's not
the case of it's not my case of course
the welfare state is a very vague term
and I would like to confine welfare to a
very small fraction of the American
population that is really poor and get
rid of all the welfare that goes to the
American middle class or well
about which everybody is now bleeding so
I'm not for the welfare state in there
and that general sense but my my agenda
I guess really is to have a rational
national discussion about what our
alternatives are in the open about and
offer the American and and I think that
we are in the eight capable of learning
to do better and I would give the
example of last year's debate about
health care reform I think there was a
case in which the options were fairly
clearly laid out and in which we did not
make the same mistakes that we made
twenty or thirty years earlier about
making enormous commitments to the
future I think we are showing a great
gain and approves and responsibilities
of our fiscal policy and I think so I'm
hopeful that we will continue to do that
but Herbert and Henry I think that a
balanced budget amendment would force
people to make those kinds of choices
our politicians as representatives of
the people would have to weigh and
assess the alternatives rather than
offloading the burden on future
generations because of physical illusion
actually a balanced budget amendment
doesn't force any member of Congress to
vote against any public expenditure or
in favor of any tax but it is discuss it
and resolve oh it doesn't even do that
they can they can if they wish they
ignore the amendment not if they do so
if they do so you will have a situation
where somebody will take it to court and
the Supreme Court will be setting budget
policy for the United States only way
you want anyone that spins beyond the
limit is in violation of federal law we
should know the anti-deficiency law and
they go to jail oh and with who is that
members of the guard agency head that
are
spending beyond the limit I can see on
the monitor that Milton wants to come in
from all right I do not believe it will
go to the courts I believe it properly
drawn out balanced budget amendment will
put the power in the hands of the
Congress and the president between them
and that you're not going to have all of
this nonsense it's big what I don't
understand I want to ask ya those who
are opposed to the balanced budget
amendment whether they think it's
inappropriate for the public at large
to set a limit on the fraction of their
income that government isn't entitled to
spend absolutely not I think it is
entirely proper we have an electoral
process that is perfectly suited to do
that now it is not it is suited to do it
on a piecemeal basis but not on an
overall whether it's appropriate for the
people of 1995 to decide for the people
of 2,095 what proportion of their income
should go to the government and I don't
think that's appropriate we're talking
about forever now if we talk about
constitutional amendment and that I
think is what just would you think it
would be wrong for the people in 1995 to
specify that the federal that
governments at all levels should never
spend a hundred percent of the national
income Henry I would just point out that
Milton is once again discussing
something that is not before the
American public what is before the
American public is an amendment he
himself has said is not well designed
and that he himself would oppose he's
discussing a different agenda I would
offer one that is before the American
public today which is the amendment that
the House of Representatives approved I
had note that isn't so because the
Senate still has to come in and in my
opinion I'm opposed to the present one
because I think if you turn this down
there will be enough of an outcry about
turning it down because of the tax
limitation proposal that within two or
three or four months you'd have a proper
balanced budget amendment passed I do
not think the public at large is opposed
to a sixty percent majority rule for
taxes I don't think they are either but
I on the other hand I don't think that
you're going to get the two-thirds vote
in both houses that you have to have to
put the amendment before the states with
the tax limitation in it I wish that
were not the case I would
I would like to even strengthen the
amendment further by putting a restraint
on the proportion of gross national
product that government may spin but
that wish is not going to come to
fruition I'm afraid just to go back to
the point that herb made my colleague
Charles Schultz has pointed out that the
founding fathers when dealing with
matters of human rights stated them with
great specificity put them in the
Constitution and to find them exactly in
discussing of procedures that would be
used inside the government they sit lay
down hard and fast rules but when it
came to setting economic policy such as
the share of gross domestic product that
should go to government they said
nothing they understood they understood
that these are the kinds of issues that
need to be resolved in each generation
through the political process by elected
officials I don't think we would want
Thomas Jefferson setting an economic
policy for our age we would not want
Alexander Hamilton setting could I just
say first of all never in their wildest
dreams would they think of a government
as large as we had today and secondly
mr. Jefferson before he died
wrote a friend and said he felt perhaps
the biggest mistake in the Constitution
was allowing deficit financing okay
thank you
Milton Friedman herb Stein Jim Miller
and Henry Aaron and thank you please
send your comments and questions to New
River media one one-five-zero 17th
Street Northwest Washington DC 2 0 0 3 6
or we can be reached via email at think
TV at aol.com for think-tank
I'm Ben wattenberg
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content